olá boa tarde hum
quando tinha cerca de maio dois anos e
começava a falar do meu voto tinha
ficado sem voz não sabia que eu adorava
rabiscado no papel e como tal utilizou o
design como maio e necessidade de
comunicar e fui imitando é uma forma
muito muito simples instantânea ou eu
vou deixando marcas braços mas como
sangari movimentos e simplesmente os
nomes e significados
infelizmente eu vou acabou por favorecer
o design não o design ficou lá comigo
[Música]
ficou tal maneira momento tão forte que
jamais poderia jamais fisicamente eu
podia tá ausência física no meu vôo não
tinha poder de remate design lembrar deu
pra sempre e foi oferecendo da minha avó
que recebendo comissão grande de
tesouros tratasse
não foi fácil
na audiência física mas também conseguir
resolvê la com de do colégio a escola da
escola do colégio e cruzava com os avós
passavam por mim ia tentando conquistar
chamava
chamava se achavam graça às vezes só
simplesmente graça
outras vezes cria o mesmo ser os meus
avós diga que eu fosse mais bonita
percebiam a minha necessidade porque
conhecia e fui crescendo assim como
mediante os avós
eu fui criando perdi a conta de quantos
foram bastante prático
fui desenvolvendo o meu gosto é o design
esta escola do andaraí
vou falar é o ramalhete que infelizmente
está no show e reconhecia as artes como
fundamentais para o desenvolvimento da
capacidade das nossas capacidades e
contar o piloto e praticando praticante
e desenvolvendo e aperfeiçoando cada vez
mais a técnica em simultâneo o vovô
também fez o professor chega para o
problema tem a ver com o fim da saída
tenha a ver com a questão do turismo
onde escolher uma frase eu escolhi o
corpo e coloco é condição de um carro e
neste caso é o amor e foi confrontada
com esta realidade de fragilidade entre
o tema entre o primitivo é tão frágil
como desenvolver todo o meu tema
é todo meu sentido artístico e todos
gostem expressar o amor com prioridade
na vida de todos nós
a última experiência que tive foi muito
forte também foi com o escultor josé
rodrigues 2015 2016 nós trabalhamos na
mesma folha de papel
desenvolvemos um trabalho comum na mesma
folha de papel
exatamente é que o que eu fiz com meu
vou lá atrás no tempo foi duro mas o
cheiro que o procurarem sempre neste
processo dan trabalhar o hipnotista
nesta relação com o meu profissionalismo
porque tinha que ser feita eu queria
passar a mensagem perfeita
fui percebendo que estava completamente
errada é técnica estava perfeita mas
esta mensagem de amor não podia ser com
esta perfeição
tinha que passar a grandeza da
fragilidade que o a moda e se eu sentir
que estava frágil doente mas quando fiz
o convite não evitou que trabalhar
comigo sabem que eu trabalhava no tejo
tem uma paixão enorme por desenvolver
esta temática e fez e quando olhava pra
eu eu percebia claramente estava
completamente em fada no sentido da
expressão da sua fragilidade
mostrou-me é importantíssimo apresentar
a finalidade mas não é minha
a nossa realidade mas com a clareza com
esta clareza da frustração
o amor também rechaça o amor também me
desencontros é dúvidas e ficado nervosa
porque então o meu trabalho que
desenvolvia em fina infinitas linhas
estilizadas
fui buscar as pinturas eróticas
rupestres lá atrás no tempo e explorados
observar com atenção onde a
homossexualidade já ali era falada
passando depois a exposições variantes
táticas gat indiana e chinesa
mas ao mesmo tempo muito limitadas eo
amadeu souza cardoso não tem nada
virótica aparentemente mas tem uma
técnica que me chamou a atenção
tem a ver com é minuciosa com lima a
linha exaustiva da minúcia camuflava
para meu em três das figuras estilizadas
as formas exatas eróticas camufladas
presse exaustão no final da rua imagem
não aquela imagem normal de 12 corpos
mas uma imagem mais global tem muitos
corpos de membros corpos infinidade de
corpos corpos
somos todos nós esta via ltda
aplicada principalmente quando é uma
mulher rica apresenta publicamente não é
fácil já tô ki tô mas todo este meu em 3
eu sei que tem um sentido e o que eu
vivi nos últimos tempos fez me perceber
que faz todo o sentido eo caminhar desta
questão frágil do a moto não faz de mim
mais frágil a não faz nem uma pessoa
frágil mas faz nem uma pessoa atenta é e
questionaram quando quando alguém nos dá
tudo o que tem tudo que sabe
embora esteja num período difícil da
vida
isso representa para nós quando eu como
eu vou com ela o tempo como eu era muito
pequena para perceber como iria marcar
no tempo como aquilo iria se tornar tão
marcante agora com josé rodrigues cvu
cada vez mais este confronto
esta ansiedade em que um desejo de
representar o amor deixa de ser mais
clara não tem ganso tem medo mostra o
medo medo de estar comigo fazer comigo
trabalhar comigo
os primeiros desenhos eu tomei a minha
linha é tão enfim controlada
sou acerto tremida
nós vamos entrar nesse meu medo
estranhamente isso mas temos de chegar
ao trabalho todos eu vou fazer isso e
mostrar o trabalho de todos não vai
realmente aquela ansiedade de ser
perfeita etapa traz neste momento eu
quero encontrar
ceição em perfeição eu quero quando
olharem efetivamente para as obras
vejo o amor e sim tomou efeito e ao
mesmo tempo perfeito com novos planos
cada vez melhor
percebemos que não pode ser usado com
uma frustração só uma coisa não correu
lá é uma experiência é uma forma de
estar é uma forma de vida mais provável
é que o processo aqui algumas imagens
fotografias de trabalhos meus não faz
muito sentido porque efetivamente não
quer limitar a ninguém as minhas imagens
o que eu quero e quando recorro ao meu
trabalho sabe onde eu explora em nossos
amores as vossas necessidades votos
confrontos diários como a vida estas
batalhas não tem sido nada fáceis mas
são surpreendidos vez enquanto
surpreendida quando alguém que acaba de
se separar faz questão de comprar um
quadro meu tonalidades preze
questionado por uma pessoa vai valer a
pena eu vou continuar
eu vou falar sobre sexo
a menina já não vemos alguém que
encontramos a conversa ao conforto é
possível principalmente a necessidade
quando eu falo assim em público nas
exposições
há um afastamento estou sozinha
mas quando apanha pode pintar comigo
este sabe como eu sou estudo sobre o
amor eu não sei nada
eu tenho um ponto de vista tenho uma
visão das coisas
por isso jamais iria colocar aqui meu
trabalho
algum dia quiser e não conhecer sabem
onde encontrar com certeza é mais
efetiva manter esta mensagem a
transmitir que não é uma opção uma opção
minha falar do amor sobre esse caso
eu como pessoa mas sim porque nós
precisamos neste nosso primeiro vai que
é o a moto e precisa descartar todos de
uma forma muito limpa honesta
exportadora e talvez um dia chegaremos
lá e percebe que é o mais importante
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]